you have a lot of sisters don't you
didn't i hear you have like a lot of
sisters yeah i have four older sisters
yeah
wow oh my gosh a lot of estrogen in one
house you made it though
i don't know if you understand how
terrified i was every single day trying
to use the bathroom
uh with these women because there's one
bathroom and you have to share it with
four women five
including my mother and you just learn
patience you learn how to sit still and
wait
oh look at them look at those little
nuggets that's the best
i love that that probably made you a
great man to date though because you
really understand women you were you had
to
to survive i mean look
here's the thing it's really important
to appreciate and respect women
like that's just that's just what that's
how you should be in this world and
i do think that rape being raised by
sisters helped a lot with my acting
because it just gave me
a chance to understand or try to
understand both sides the masculine and
the feminine and try to bring that
into my work so yeah big ups to my
sisters to black women big ups to you
kelly clarkson okay thank you
thank you want more fun stuff i thought
so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure